hi I'm Evan Carmichael and welcome to
another edition of ask Evan in today's
video I'm going to answer question from
one of my readers Nitin who asks hi Evan
I saw your video in startup capital on
YouTube and the comments people have
provided it's an excellent resource and
I believe that it's very relevant
learning material for young
entrepreneurs and professionals I was
just wondering whether you apply any
methodology in developing your video
materials and what you do with all the
different video materials so to answer
your question Nitin most of the videos
that I do are coming from user feedback
so their questions from people like you
who want some answers regarding their
business and I try to create these quick
videos to help them out in the past I
used to answer emails and it was getting
a little overwhelming and trying to
answer a lot of emails and helping
people out and I thought that by
creating videos I'd also be able to help
other people who might be having the
same problem so instead of just helping
one personnel be able to reach a wider
audience and help more entrepreneurs
over so most of the videos I do our that
nature there you know ask gavin their
questions and part of this series some
of the videos that will do will also be
on famous entrepreneur profiles so we'll
look at how someone like Donald Trump or
Oprah Winfrey got started and lessons
you can learn from their success and
those ones might be sponsored by a
company who's trying to get more
involved with my website but most of the
videos that I do there's no revenue
model behind it it's just trying to help
entrepreneurs and kind of be resource
and when i first started my website
there wasn't a business model behind it
either and eventually as a groom we
became more helpful more useful we were
able to develop an advertising model
that work for us so I'm just trusting
that the dots will connect and by
creating a lot of value and making these
videos it helps a lot of people and the
business model will will come about have
confidence in that and by following your
passion almost always works out for you
so I hope that answers your question if
you have any more please leave it in the
comment below I'd also love to hear your
thoughts and feedback if you have other
questions and please give the video a
thumbs up to
and stay tuned for next episode
you